what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I've been sitting here for like
the last I don't know 15 minutes maybe
I'm talking to the people on periscope I
love talking to my fans on periscope
those guys who don't know you can find
me on Twitter at comics explain and
whenever I go live on periscope it
automatically tweets out so periscope of
course is a live streaming app that most
people know about by now but I talk to
my fans all the time and I hit everybody
up and I was like guys I'm running out
of ideas like I'm not sure what I should
talk about and like all like fans just
feeding me ideas remember the Rob for
feeding me ideas and they were like just
talk about whether or not the old
cartoon shows hold up and so we are
we're gonna be talking about x-men the
animated series and we're not gonna
approach this from an academic
standpoint right like we're not gonna
take the the clean prints gaming
approach but if you guys don't know who
that is you guys need to go check out
clean prints gaming that do that guy do
it's amazing dude I love that guy's
videos they're really really well
produced but we're not gonna do this
from an academic standpoint this is
literally gonna be what amounts to an
op-ed piece the personal opinion of me
Rob on whether or not x-men the animated
series was as great as we remember it
being now I'm gonna preface this by
saying I am biased as hell and I regret
nothing
I love X been the animated series I grew
up on that show I love that show so much
that was my introduction to Marvel
Comics so so little commerce explained I
could have been more than like seven
years old so this show hits TV screens
and my dad grew up reading comic books
funnily enough where I started my
channel off as comics or as Marvel
explained my dad grew up reading DC oh
he loved DC he loved Green Lantern of
all the people he loved Green Lantern
but extra the animated series hits the
market I don't think we caught it when
it first came out I think that we saw it
after it was already out but it was a
bonding experience for myself and my dad
because he got to sort of rekindle this
interest encounter books that had long
since lost me he went to the Navy
different things like that and I was
learning about them for the very first
time and that set the stage for me you
know developing and interests and
characters that weren't really in x-men
the animated series but were part of the
Marvel Universe you know like Captain
America different things like that it
was huge but looking back I mean maybe
it is because I'm a little bit biased
here but that show is every bit as
awesome as I remember it being you know
and I could fire it up on Hulu right now
and I could go back and watch remember
watching those episodes about six months
ago now there are key episodes that
stand out to me more than others but
overall like I could watch the show from
start to finish until you get to season
five when it becomes trashed but I could
go from like you know seasons 1 through
and literally enjoy every minute
matter-of-fact is who's like I'm
recording this that's exactly what I'm
gonna do but you know I could go in just
and just enjoy every single one of them
because when it came the x-men the
animated series it wasn't just an
archetypical superhero comic books show
that was nonsensical right it wasn't
super funds Super Friends was nonsense
in a lot of ways I mean after all it was
because of Super Friends everybody
walked away with the ideology that
Aquaman talks to fish and rides
you know rides sea horses around the
ocean but that's been the animated
series there was a lot of depth there
there was a lot of complexity there you
know the characters had character they
had a motion it wasn't just like you
know Professor X and Wolverine and
Cyclops and those guys just running
around and there's the enemy and we have
to fight them you had that because I
mean that's what you do when you have a
show but they clearly developed a love
triangle between Cyclops Wolverine and
Jean Grey there was the grudging respect
between Cyclops and Wolverine I mean
there were these great things that
focused so much on the characters the
villains themselves Magneto I loved
magneto and x-men the animated series
because they took the whole concept from
the comics that magneto was hell-bent on
the fact that he was right and everybody
else was wrong that was a stance like
you've watched you watch x-men the
animated series you look at magneto
magneto is a guy who in the comics grew
up in World War two watch the
concentration camps unfold watch how his
Jewish people were treated you know by
the Germans and how so many individuals
were disenfranchised of their rights
they were slaughtered different things
like that and when his mutant powers
developed the argument was I'm never
going to let that happen to mutant kind
and while that is an extreme perception
it is a relatable perception because it
takes this idea that there are people
who feel helpless in different points in
their lives and then it suddenly says
but what if you had the ability to not
be helpless and that was the whole idea
behind it because it was one of those
things where magneto would stand
staunchly in the face of the x-men and
everybody in existence and say I'm right
you're wrong and that's just the way it
is but at the same time they were also
like these tense moments like you'd
watch the show and it would be like so
why don't the x-men just like kill all
the humans if humans are such a hassle
and all they want to do is tear the
x-men down then why don't they just like
kill them all and just be like you know
what humans like we're kind of tied to
you pardon my language so like you're
all gonna die and then we're gonna come
back and then we'll just kind of rule
the earth and then we'll kill any
baseline humans we can find you know it
was different things like that but it
was as much political as it was
superhero you know action because the
x-men have historically always been this
Marvel Comics allegory for
pressed groups in society people will
say is african-americans not always the
x-men represent a multi-faceted group
basically anyone who's ever been
oppressed by any other class is
represented and the concept of the x-men
whether you're a person of Asian descent
a person of you know Latin American
descent but it's that whole idea of
oppression this kind of signified in the
x-men stories and even saw that I mean
basically you had the friends of
humanity and the friends of humanity
were the Marvel Comics and the TV show
equivalent of the Klan one of the things
they didn't have was William Stryker the
religious fundamentalists who believed
it was his mission from God to kill
mutants that was a really really cool
concept from the comics God allows man
kills is really the only part that it
matters who really the only story he was
ever in that William Stryker was in the
never mattered but it was a
groundbreaking story I was huge what God
loves man kills came out you go and look
at any of the letters pages you go look
at any of the reviews online forum posts
the whole nine yards it's you you look
at any list look up like the top twenty
stories that defined the x-men and God
loves man kills will most likely be
among that list and if it's not then the
person who made it doesn't know what
they're talking about because I like
this story but the fact remains here
it's one of those interesting things it
really fits in with the nature of the
idea that the x-men are constantly
struggling against an oppressive force
that would rather see them eliminated
than work with them and taking that
concept and rolling it over into the TV
show allow for all these great political
and social engagements and topics of
discussion and different things like
that and then there's the idea of just
hopelessness fighting against an enemy
that cannot be defeated namely
apocalypse and let me tell you all
something apocalypse man apocalypse from
x-men the animated series there will
never be a better depiction of
apocalypse then from x-men the animated
series Jude the guy's one-liners all man
whatever I was watching an episode of
x-men the animated series and apocalypse
showed up I was like oh snap son you're
just about to get real son because he
had these amazing quips there's two
great moments from the history of
apocalypse in x-men the animated series
the first one is time fugitives it was
where Cable had to travel back to the
present day in order to help apocalypse
develop and release the legacy virus it
was someone was launched but basically
the way it turned out is that the legacy
virus was initially released and then it
devastated the whole of humanity Bishop
went back in time did something and it
changed cables future and so cable had
to go back in time stopped Bishop and
then exposed Wolverine to the legacy
virus
the legacy virus would encounter his
healing factor and then a cure could be
synthesized but there's this amazing
battle where they're fighting off
against apocalypse and God what is it
what is it he says oh he says he says I
am the rocks on the eternal Shore crash
against me and be broken dude it was so
bad he's like I am the rocks on the
eternal Shore crush against me and be
broken and it was it was like in the
heat of the battle it was like dude this
guy's wrecking the x-men and he still
got time for quips there's this point
where Bishop where it's like all the
x-men are like blasting apocalypse with
everything they have Wolverine is like
ah you know and he's attacking him with
his claws or like bishops shooting his
laser beams from his guns and like
cables doing what he can as Cyclops is
shooting his optic glass you know and
like rogues throwing stuff at him and
storms using lightning bolts and nothing
works and apocalypse just looks at him
and he was what is what is he says he
says I cannot be harmed I cannot be
defeated watch me and tremble for I
bring the purity of oblivion to you
world dude I was like that's the most
boss thing I've ever heard dude if I'm
fighting against a guy and what I'm
doing and I've got superpowers and what
I'm doing does nothing and the guy just
starts busting out quips like that I'm
like all right peace like I'm out
because continuing to fight this guy
means almost certain doom and it's kind
of cool because in before cable went
back into the past in the original
conflict between the x-men and and an
apocalypse apocalypse grew to like 2,000
feet tall and then just incinerated him
he was just like x-men and then totally
obliterated him and that was the end of
the x-men they were just totally
incinerated by apocalypse which was a
great little moment because it showed
you the reality of what it meant if they
faced off against them if apocalypse was
hell-bent on killing the x-men done
that's it there's there's nothing more
to and than that they're just out of the
picture that's all there is but then
there's this second encounter the work
Havel runs into apocalypse and his own
future in his own time line because
apocalypse is immortal basically and
cable breaks into his tomb it's a story
called Beyond Good and Evil there's a
four part episode which is really cool
where apocalypse captures all the most
powerful mutants on earth basically and
like hey ball shows up in apocalypses
temple breaks in there and then triggers
a trap and apocalypse is just like
feeble mutants and he's it's hilarious
it's one of the funniest things ever
evil mutant you
challenge apocalypse again because like
they're facing off time and time again
it's always like blasphemer you shall
pay for your hubris and it's just like
dude this guy's lines you know this
guy's lines are just are so amazing you
know it's it's do all know there's a
point where arc angel
we're Warren Worthington after he's
transformed into Archangel by apocalypse
the episode is called obsession and what
ends up happening is Archangel is
obsessed with the idea of finding a
weakness and apocalypse and he isn't
like hiring all these different people
who are studying like all these
different hieroglyphics and you know
historical texts from Egypt about like
what people believe apocalypse to be and
how a lot of people thought he was a god
and like Warren Worthington is freaking
out because he's like he's not
indestructible and then you end up
finding out later on in the episode one
of the archaeologists was actually
apocalypse in disguise he'd shape-shift
into the shape-shifted into the form of
one of the archaeologists and have been
tricking Warren Worthington the whole
time but when Warren Worthington takes
what he believes to be the weakness of
apocalypse and tries to use it in a
battle of pocalypse is dude he starts
talking trash the whole time he was like
returned to me sweet Horseman death and
all shall be forgiven
dude it's do the guy who voiced him was
so cool and then there's other stuff
he's like what oh my god one man's worth
okay so one man's worth was this amazing
it was a two-part episode and it was an
amazing episode that was a continuation
of a previous episode where Bishop
traveled back in time for the first time
anyway the way that's played out is it
initially picked up with this massive
battle between like mutants and humans
and you it was it was so cool because
you had like ant-man in there either it
was either it was ant-man or it was
giant man but they grabbed a they
grabbed a technology of Pym particles to
like increase people in size and it was
like it just all these different armies
of these normal humans with superpowers
different things like that but it was
one of these things were like cities
were obliterated you know and it was
like dude this is a really really bleak
future but you saw villains like mr.
sinister teaming up with what passed for
the x-men basically this giant unified
front of mutants trying to fend off
against humans and come to find out what
had happened was that one of the enemies
of Bishop a guy named Trevor Fitzroy had
traveled into the past at the request of
master mole who was basically this
massive Sentinel that created smaller
sentinels and it eventually became
sentient and took over the world but
because of this Trevor Fitzroy travels
into the past
and then kills Charles Xavier while he's
in college and so because Xavier never
formed the x-men they weren't there for
some key moment or some key event either
that or there was no one to try to stem
the tide of anti-mutant sentiment and so
he ended up just having it all come to a
head and there was just massive civil
war that broke out planet-wide between
mutants and humans and so Bishop travels
to what's supposed to be his future only
to find out that everything has gone
crazy magneto is leading this group Jim
oh they had mimic they had mimicked in
that episode people along people don't
know who he is mimic was a guy who had
the ability to copy the powers of others
with any level like with absolute
accuracy I could do it any number of
times and could copy more than one power
so like the most iconic image of the
mimic is when he's got the optic visor
of Cyclops
he has the physical structure of Beast
before he became all blue and furry
he's got the wings of Angel and
something else like a member what the
other one is but the result is that he
was there too like he was fighting among
you know these various forces and so on
and so forth anyway Bishop ends up going
back in time and he basically saves a
life of Xavier and then everything is
kind of fixed after that but there were
so many great stories so many alternate
realities stories that went on with
things like that
and don't forget the battle cry of
Wolverine so Wolverine couldn't kill
people and expert in the animated series
he had to kill robots so he would tear
the sentinels to shreds but the battle
cry of war in every time war of rain ran
into battle he'd pop his claws and you'd
only ever say one of two things either
he would he would just shout Jean he
would just be like Jean or he would just
be like this one's for you morph
everything was for morph like morph died
fifty years beforehand I get like if
Norfolk died fifty years beforehand
Wolverine would just go running about
this one's for you morph it's like Jude
Wolverine like morph died more five
years ago like it at the time it was
epic as it was it was so epic but now
looking back it is kind of like dude
like really like all of us all of his
attacks were named after Jean Jude dude
I loved x-men the animated series yeah I
would I would most certainly say X been
the animated series
definitely holds up I mean not even
because I'm none because I'm biased
towards it but just because when I go
back and I look at that to me a hallmark
of a show is that it's just as good ten
years after year after after you first
saw it as it was when you first saw that
feeling of excitement that feeling of
mad
to see what happens next that feeling
remains whether you've seen it a
thousand times whether you see that ten
thousand times that excitement that
interests that passion for that show is
always there to me that's the defining
hallmark of what makes those shows great
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the robb quark if you guys
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more videos like this didn't make sure
you drop a like let me know down in the
comments section what you guys think
about expa in the animated series I'm
sure a lot of you guys are post comments
anyway but let me know whether or not
you liked it and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]